[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about the
future faster we're gonna be talking a
lot about innovation in disruption and
we have the man for it mark Bing or
what's up man thanks for coming out of
the show thanks for having me
really appreciate it super excited for
this conversation I'm really glad that
Nick connected us along now and the
cries of shout out shout out to like
that now amazing place yes yes and Nick
actually left us with like what did he
give us he gave us the the coin and the
long now coin and also he brought like
what was it 10 year old scotch was it it
was it was very nice to Penn he brought
it yeah so our multi-year multi-year de
holic beverage I have some of that stuff
yeah
hang from the bottle on the ceiling so
yeah yeah and you guys are tight too and
you got the coin rolling back there we
got one over here two on the shelf so we
got two two of those puppies nice nice
yeah shout out to long now look at this
beautiful the Bristlecone pine and they
throw in the zero to start the year to
show how you mindful keep you mindful of
how old civilization actually is yeah
and even then it's like yeah yeah yeah
yeah so huge shoutout so long now mark
super happy to have you you've been
doing this for over a dozen years now
which is crazy and that is nuts to me
that you've been doing this over a dozen
years because you look really young you
look like you're in you know mid 20s
late 20 so when when this is when this
is sure yeah yeah yeah you can have I'll
give you some more gary support set now
you were teaching me a lot about this
and it was actually really interesting
learning about this from you and a lot
of this in
even before we get into this sort of
this sort of idea of of radical
innovation in disruption and building
the future faster and how these
different corporations can structure
themselves in order to be able to have
these innovation labs you can work work
with Innovation Lab which is where
you're at now and as a deep tech agent
and prior to that at Lux research so I
want to know more about you know how did
you even get into doing innovation lab
stuff like what was your upbringing like
so that you got into this well you know
is it's you know two big factors were
the places I grew up one was on Air
Force bases when I was little so it's
surrounded by aircraft you know the I
was a huge fan of space and we'd go to
NASA and places like that so the whole
aerospace industry was a really big
inspiration from the time when I was you
know a born basically I first I was born
in Germany and my first flight was when
I was about eight days old and I flew to
Greece where my parents we're living I
wanted to be with them because you know
I was an infant so yeah yeah it's kinda
itchy now but you had Sofia Ferguson
with us oh yeah okay yeah next time but
yeah so I'm Black Hawk crew chief oh
great okay
well so yeah you get the fascination
with things that fly it's kind of the
ultimate you know human dream it's you
go back to Icarus and even these really
primal myths the ability to fly is this
superpower and now we've got it so that
was really and still remains a huge
inspiration for me and then when my dad
left the military he went into went to
Xerox and so this was the late 70s early
80s and the personal computers just
starting to come out of the lab so we
have this place not very far from here
called Park Palo Alto Research Center
that was Xerox is like moonshot program
in the 70s and they were looking at a
lot of the office equipment they made
like electric typewriters and things
like that
coming either if not well not obsolete
but they're seeing a lot of competition
and so they amended their personal
computer and so when I was a like middle
schooler we had this $40,000 workstation
at home that I got to like do my
homework on so again seeing not just
that technology come in but seeing the
old technologies like typewriters go out
in person you know through my dad and
through my own experience was a it was
also really kind of you know seminal for
you know how have you technology in the
world now so a lot of this was actually
father being involved at cutting-edge
tech yeah yeah that got you into it yeah
and I give my father credit for that but
I would also give my mother credit she
was a nurse and so about about ten years
ago I had a little bit of an existential
Technology crisis where the stuff I was
working with technology wise was I felt
getting kind of boring a lot of the
personal computer stuff that I thought
was gonna last forever and so I went
back I was gonna be an aerospace
engineer fulfill that dream and I had a
biochem elective that just blew my mind
yeah and so then I went I pursued that
pretty heavily for a while so I worked
in a neurology lab and a bioengineering
lab at UCSF and got you know hands-on
experience with stem cells and bio
nanotechnology and things like that so
it's this really weird synthesis of very
very different fields but once you're
again once you've kind of used to that
then you see those patterns you know how
drug delivery systems and you know
electric typewriters have similar types
of evolutionary paths so that gets us
into the future faster yeah yeah so I
kind of want to know about you know to
take us because that this is really
interesting it's it's the history of
innovation and what it's but when it's
what it's done right you were giving us
the example of Xerox Xeroxes it's uh
what is it it's Park what is it Park
Palo Alto Research Center yeah a
research center Park yep and so that
Center is where this the
first electronic electronic keyboard for
type typing was right yes yeah so
basically what they you could see the
evolution this way and I say evolution
in a really literal sense you know
machines evolve of the same way
organisms do so typewriters at the time
if you made a mistake like when they
were mechanical typewriters you had to
go into some was gone
well you had this like white goop called
whiteout and you'd like paint over with
a little paintbrush some white stuff on
the letter you made a mistake you'd back
it up and you'd hit the same key again
so there's this ribbon with some ink you
had a hammer with a shape of a letter on
it and it would you press that into the
paper and that's right it would do yes
yeah right so so yeah it's so funny
because I'm probably and unless the gen
Z kids that come in now unless they
actually go and like see those and like
go and actually write with them they
probably will never my kids are
fascinated by them so they they've
actually spent allowance buying and
mechanical typewriters and you turn
these things on and they they're
electric and they make noise they sound
like you're you know starting a chainsaw
like they is they have these these
motors spinning stuff up so it's really
funny and but anyway says here arts may
be machines they're like oh well you
know what we could do is we're gonna put
one of these little LCD screens or elet
yes LCD screens that allow you to see a
few characters in advance what you've
typed so if you make a mistake you can
correct it on the screen with whatever
eight or twenty characters before it you
commit it to paper yeah so they're like
you've just saved people hours a day
probably like if you're writing a letter
step was to put it on an LCD screen and
then and then once you do like a
paragraph then it would it may be like
then it would print it on to the piece
of paper right yeah actually doesn't
word or to a word or two onto the paper
yeah you had a really tiny little screen
yeah so you can think of that screen is
like evolving so that you get bigger
high resolution and this is where we get
into the the structure of this
innovation but so that screen got bigger
and better and so now you can see the
entire page like writer companies were
thinking this was coming well they could
they had didn't have that technology
they were just doing
the best to keep up with you know
keeping the Hammers from sticking to
each other and making it quiet and stuff
like that right so you've got this
hundred-year-old technology it's going
it's just cruising along from the 1800's
into the early 1980s mid 1980s yeah and
these personal computers coming out and
they were ridiculously expensive like I
said $40,000 to start yeah right
so on the grand and it can do so much
more than if it's in our pocket oh you
know what's easy can do is like as cheap
it would be a few tens of dollars these
days what those computers gave you right
so nothing yeah but at the time $40,000
is actually a business case for that
because for like a secretary to type one
one letter was maybe five dollars and if
you figure out how many people you know
make how many mistakes how many letters
they write and all these other things we
can do with computer it actually was a
viable business case now what happened
was Apple came along and and said we can
do that forty thousand dollar computer
for four thousand or two thousand
dollars he said and so Xerox actually
while they did have a business around
this for a few years
ultimately they lost it they lost it to
an agile new company so that was all the
big lesson from what a I'm an agile I'm
sorry I said in comment but they would
be an agile competitor directors the
incumbent I like how you call it an
agile competitor versus an incumbent
right we kind of see so many
incumbencies right now threatened
totally yeah yeah and it's been
happening for the longest time the first
person that made the wheel and like who
made the wheel better than RAM etc yeah
so this is so this is why I think this
is such a hot topic right now is that we
live in we're the first generation to
really live in a time where we've seen
that evolution happen in a time span we
can remember so the wheel yeah
disrupted whatever was before that and
you know over the course of thousands of
years
things like sewing machines also took
decades to really evolve but digital
technologies evolved in such a span that
you have a memory of something being
science fiction the first time you held
an iPhone I bet you remember that yeah
right and now we're like okay so iPhone
hasn't really changed for 10 years
what's what's Apple's next act so when
you've seen these technologies go from
again science fiction to nostalgia
that's kind of the path now that
a five or ten year pattern not a 50 or
100 year pattern yeah so what you can do
so this I see this a little bit like the
way we went from you know superstitions
about things like eclipses or the
weather or the crops to a science if you
have enough historical record you can
say oh yeah eclipses like follow this
regular pattern so I can start to
predict them yeah and if it's something
you can actually you can't affect in
Eclipse but you can affect crops so if
you know that pattern for crops or the
weather you can start to say okay it's
not gonna rain I need to water or it's
gonna rain so much
I better not water or whatever you need
to do so now we're seeing these
technologies happen you know so quickly
that that data is you know abundant
right in front of us and looking for
those those patterns kind of you know
saying what's the similarity between how
again a medicine evolves and how a car
evolves and how say spaceflight evolves
that's that's what this is all about yes
yes let's give another example that you
were teaching us about we all remember
playing with our first note was a lot of
us remember playing with our first Nokia
phones and because especially the game
snake was so great yeah yeah it's the
Angry Birds of mobile the first of the
first mobile phone yeah yeah Wolfert
yeah yeah but and then and then crazy
they were such a huge company and then
again dead after massive peak yeah yeah
so you know Nokia was you know a
legendary company I do it changed thick
you know course of its nation's history
it was absolutely Finland right one of
the most successful you know companies
technology companies and real rocket in
the you know early to mid 90s and they
actually had smartphones yeah they just
didn't really want to sell them that bad
I mean there was it was not their main
business and so just the same way you
know Xerox got you know beat by by Apple
Apple also beat Nokia with smart phones
so black buyer was also in there
remember blackberry that was kind of
like older so it would remember when
Barack Obama was a candidate he was the
cool candidate the tech-savvy candidate
because he had a smart phone well a
blackberry anyway yeah and
and now you know BlackBerry's completely
obsolete yeah so again in this in a span
of time that we now can remember you've
seen these things going from being like
so cool and amazing to like wow I
haven't seen those because a lot of the
market probably they had a big chunk
they had a huge chunk of the market and
they really had a unique position as
like essentially began at a computer
phone combination sack with the keyboard
right yeah yeah
so when emails wirelessly yeah with on
the mobile on-the-go yeah it was like
and and they thought that so this is
around 2009 they thought that they were
completely unbeatable kids had this
physical keyboard and some other stuff
and you know you can again go through
the history of this and see exactly when
the CEO or when you know when they made
a decision when R&D came out with
something it didn't work and and see
that and it looks exactly like how Kodak
made its decisions tonight get into
digital codec and been a digital camera
alright lost the film business lost the
camera business lost everything and so
the fact that companies keep doing this
yeah like you see these patterns so this
is so this is what we do now I say okay
you're a car maker and the autonomous
vehicle is a new technology it's like
the smartphone of cars what are you
gonna do about that or you might be in
you might make smartphones and you say
well what about neural interfaces this
sounds kinda like science fiction I've
only seen like why would I ever need
that and that's something that will come
in the future is that going to be
disruptive in the same way to those
incumbent industries and funny enough I
actually I actually had a project with a
phone manufacturer that that I won't
name but in the early in the mid-90s
they said gosh you know we think we
could put a camera on a phone what would
we do with that like oh that's really
hard maybe you'd send pictures while you
were shopping you know we had a really
hard time coming up with saying always
2020 yeah but then though you know it's
like oh yeah yeah we're trying to think
of how to integrate maybe like quantum
computing or neural bases or biotech
into cell phones or whatever into a
technology that handheld tech yeah yeah
and then 10 years we'll all be like oh
of course we absolutely will yeah I
remember people saying
that time why would I ever want to check
email on my phone yeah that was such a
bad idea so I think if you don't start
with bad ideas you're really not um
you're not gonna be challenging you're
you're you're inside the box thinking
right right so I want it this is
actually really interested segue you
were starting to get there and so you we
were we were giving these examples of
the history of innovation in the history
of what were once supergiant's at the
peaks of their fields and growth
collapsing and now at Lux Research
previously for you for 12 years and now
an Innovation Lab this is what you've
been doing is going in and working with
the teams at these bigger corporations
and also some startups as well and being
like these are the some of the key
principles in the fields that you want
to innovate in or here some of the
leading research right agile companies
are doing and that's why they've been
the organization you've been working
with have been able to move fast and
yeah and stay afloat and alive and
innovating yeah II hope so that way it's
good for them it's also good for us yeah
the clients stay alive but yeah the so
I'd say there's there's three things one
is this again this framework saying hey
there's a pattern to how innovation
happens the winners and losers and you
know we have a lot of historical
examples and we have a lot of data also
about that pattern then you can say so
what is what looks like it's a you know
in the future what would be the types of
things that could potentially change or
disrupt what you work with and some of
those things are not gonna work out some
of those things are gonna you know run
into economic or technical or other
types of problems but some of them could
potentially be worth watching and and
could change your industry in the way
that these things have in the past so
the third thing is then to take those
those ideas about the intersection of
the past and the potential future and
start to create artifacts or films or
movies or some way to really embody that
so that you know the seven weeks that
you
spent like intensively thinking about
what could happen we could go right what
could go wrong isn't really easy to
communicate to a wider circle of people
they can add ideas that can you know
make other types of changes yeah
so okay no give us some some examples
from today's day about how this is
working out because there's a extech
exponential technologies we're going in
all different types of directions at
rocket speeds yeah and so how the hell
do you guys even synthesize the
information to try and teach other
people what's you know what's going on
it's crazy yeah yeah it is definitely
very hard in it I feel like it's getting
harder but the you know the same way
that what is making it harder to track
is also making it easier to track so we
use you know what we used to track on
paper then on spreadsheets now we have
AI to help
just scrape tens of thousands of patents
and find which ones are about the type
of thing we're talking about look at
news stories or other you know primary
sources of information yeah and then
that really allows us to kind of take an
odd job it's actually easier now because
those tools are they eliminated a lot of
the drudgery that we used to do with
like web searching and phone calls and
and Excel spreadsheets now we have a
machine to help us with um and we can
focus on where they creative stuff I
don't but I am interestingly enough I
don't know if the automation of the
drudgery processes has outpaced the
Exponential's of the multi disciplines
that have just been popping up right
that's a very interesting yeah we don't
we I mean there's some rate limiting
factor somewhere and so that those those
synthesizing you know algorithms if you
will all that although that those tools
are also helping people develop things
more quickly yeah so again this is part
of this yes it's like an arms race and
because we can't you know if we can't
imagine things we're probably not gonna
just you know come up with him there is
this field I've actually gotten
extremely you know into in the last few
years called artificial creativity this
is like AI applied to things like music
and visual arts and things like that
shoutouts a
my my increment yeah Alysia we had her
on this ok she's awesome she's doing
computational music right yeah it's ok
so the again tracking this and I can
talk at length about this but you know
I've looked at when were the times that
when did machines get better than humans
at different things that we think of as
creative so like playing tic-tac-toe
it's it's a there's a creative thought
process going on there but most adults
think take to toe is a very boring game
because once you know the rules you can
always win or at least never lose right
so computers learn to do that in 1952
program called oxo right then in 90s
deep blue beat you know Garry Kasparov
in chess just last year 2017 you know
yeah alphago so you can look at these
different games there's it there's a
history here and the reason the the sort
of speed of improvement has to do with
things like how many degrees of freedom
does the game have and how many you know
how much does rule-breaking help you and
yeah like there's no rule breaking in
tic-tac-toe but in chess you can come up
something really intuitive that doesn't
want to say like we yeah yeah more
degrees enough right yeah right so music
is pretty well bounded I mean there are
notes there's like there's there's
certainly a lot is well bounded it's
considered well compared compared to
something visual arts where you can you
can have a lot more degrees approach
right you can have colors you have
shapes and there's a lot of symbolic
representation the music is still a
sequence it's a temporal sequence
there's frequencies so you can like as a
there's a math problem music way easier
than the visual or visual and so so
computers can basically in a lot of
genres of music absolutely crush humans
like the other than almost every human
and we think of this as new and kind of
scary but there was a point then 80s
that was that they could sound like a
human playing a violin or a piano just
thinking since synthesized it sounds so
yeah right we don't think of that
remarkable anymore and in a few years at
two or three years we will not be
surprised like now you listen to spot a
lot of our music is computational yeah
so you so you
served so we have computational curation
right now
that's what Spotify and Pandora do yeah
right and that's great you don't need to
go and learn the names of all these are
that's what even our new speeds do a
price are socially for better and for
worse yeah but we're getting to a point
where that that synthetic music if you
will that that artificial creativity
applied the music will be such that you
know it might it will it will play a
stream of music that's generated for you
on the fly you know based on your mood
or your activities or whatever you're
doing this is what already happens in
video gaming generative music that
responds to the sort of the situation so
that sounds kind of science fictiony but
it's actually already here that's
interesting you went to artificial
creativity first computational
creativity if you will there's a lot to
talk about just there but there's so
much more so this is you know the the
disruptions that have been going on are
just so fascinating to me and you're
right you've been there over the last
like decade with the disruptions you
gave this example I thought it was
really good you gave the example of when
you were doing work with autonomous
field but Thomas vehicles and this was
2012-2013 and all these automotive
manufacturers were like Kodak you're
just like Blockbuster they just they
didn't see the lead side they didn't
make the moves the innovation
departments didn't keep on it yeah well
and this is where it's so they were they
were all pursuing autonomous vehicles
there's been a there was a DARPA
challenge around autonomous vehicles
that they were all competing in so they
were aware of the idea but the the
concept is still like yeah like 50 years
from now you'll drive into a brand new
neighborhood and there will be special
roads that are only for autonomous
vehicles right and and it so it was it
was a it was a this on the vision it was
a Miss on the vision right and so in
2013 Google basically said well we have
been driving our autonomous vehicles
between our
you and you know San Jose or Santa Clara
offices because vision of law that said
we couldn't do that so we just did it
and and that really shocked the whole
auto industry and and well Google also
said it and by the way we're gonna have
this ready for road ready stuff in 2018
so this year so they predicted in 2013
the bus just got the approvals from the
massive like Sunnyvale like pretty good
at predicting the future right because
they are inventing it yeah right and so
but the car makers so car makers
traditionally couldn't get like a new
color of leather seats or like you know
something really trivial in cars buy in
five years electric windows or you know
cruise control these are all things that
took 30 years to roll out basically and
so for something really really massively
changing like self-driving cars to be
ready in five years was like totally
dismiss that but Carlos Cohen who at the
time was CEO of Nissan and Renault and
then seviche well just Nissan anyway he
was at Stanford at the time and talking
about some stuff that they were working
on with electric cars and this
autonomous vehicle question kept coming
up like what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do and he said well we've seen
what Google did to phone manufacturers
like Nokia and we don't want that to
happen to us because again Google didn't
Google doesn't make phones they brought
out Android it was actually Android not
the iPhone that that killed Nokia and
all these guys and what that did was you
had you know third tier phone
manufacturers like Samsung which is the
top tier one right now was like nobody
had a Samsung they make terrible phones
and that so android gave samsung the
tools to beat nokia yeah and why
motorola and blackberry and even apple
so so those those types of disruptions
like if the Google car could basically
be a platform that say Tata or cheerio
this like kind of unheard of car
manufacturers could use because the
things that make cars you know really
exciting would make them exciting
anymore
that's a mortal threat to the industry
and that's pretty much what we see
happening right now
there's dozens of self-driving car
startups even just here in California so
that pattern that like remember that all
the little PC manufacturers overthrowing
the the mainframe makers because of
Windows and stuff like that that's
that's at least and all those stars are
aligned in the same way so it doesn't
mean in China there's apparently now
dozens of electrical vehicle meant
manufacturers and but belief Shinzon's
went completely electric on their bus
system things like that
tens of thousands of electric electric
and autonomous vehicles for some
technological reasons kind of go hand in
hand I they yeah like I OTS very well
done with electric and in autonomous
yeah yeah and so that's that's gonna be
that's very interesting um you know
let's take us to a current day example
now with Innovation Lab study so that
was Cubs five years ago great example
now we're at doing things like the
transit and in Sweden this example is
very interesting because you were
teaching us you were teaching you
beforehand like you go through the
airport you have to go through you know
our two of security and chuckling and
all this stuff but you get on a train
where is really no security yeah so now
you get to do interesting things like
potentially facial recognition also
other kind of stuff to detect emotional
states right yes interesting so this so
this is a good example of where there's
an unmet need the the the the railway
system and actually transport system
over you know broadly which includes
other things like buses and and and
stuff like that yeah public transit
right I'll have the same issue is they
don't they don't have the time and money
to have everybody screened before you
get on a bus for example and who would
want to do that but at the same time
they know that there's risk if they're
running and and and that's a problem so
the the challenge though is that people
when they feel like they're under
surveillance they actually start to
strike back against the thing it's there
to protect them um so you see this like
in the UK people are protesting these
you know Cece camp CCD
CCTV cameras everywhere here we've had
Edward Snowden and all these young
people are actually resisting these
systems that are ostensibly in place to
protect them well then there's also you
go all the way to go authoritarian cider
right so yeah suffice so there's a
natural tendency for them to that and
there's a lot of you know kind of fear
and controversy like a good example is
this in China they have this Social
Credit System at there so you're
developing you know and not to I don't
know enough about that say where that's
a good idea or bad idea I'm kind of
withholding judgment which tells you how
open I am to bad ideas because most
people would say this is the worst thing
ever but not really on your side but in
terms of always wanting to be outside of
the box always free thinking always
gonna take the risk with potentially bad
ideas just to be risky and explore
things yeah yeah I mean and this isn't a
like a moral position I'm taking it's
more of a based on my experience a lot
of things that we think of is totally
untenable terrible idea worst ever
that's actually an indicator that you're
onto something interesting from not that
you're right were you were very often
wrong it's in my own like being wrong
several times on these things is what
makes me just withhold a little judgment
on that let's say that the authoritarian
could maybe evolved into decentralized
potentially yeah and then that could be
more interesting yeah that and that's
precisely the thing we're trying to do
in this situation with Sweden is if
Sweden has a very very strong
anti-authoritarian you know personal
integrity like all these types of
cultural values that means they don't
want to have like a US or UK or Russia
or China style surveillance program but
they also know that if that's the only
alternative that exists in the market
then they will have to buy it and use it
in some way so what they want to do is
develop a third way that really
integrates against some of these
individual give distributed power to the
individual those other things that makes
this less potentially you know less
potential for misuse less
authoritarianism and less of that type
of stuff so there's a lot of conflicting
social and cultural and other types of
forces here and that's what we're trying
to balance yeah yeah that's actually
really interesting that you brought up
the social cultural side of things as
well because we were just talking about
the geopolitical differences you have to
deal with different social and cultural
values while you're dealing with
innovation right and that's calm further
complicating because it's adding
variables to how people lay off right
yeah
well the so the the dirty secret about
technology innovation is actually it's a
social phenomenon and and that we think
of it as like it's all about patents or
about scientific discoveries and things
like that but all the frameworks that we
have for accurately predicting
technological for example technology
adoption come from non what we don't
think of as technologies so you know for
example a classic example would be like
let's say there's a fashion in Paris and
1800s for wearing purple feathers in
your hat something like that
so how how's that spread like what how
does one year become the year everybody
has to have a purple feather and photo
meme right exactly so how did that
spread and so there were sociologists
back in the day that looked at you know
who's the person that first wore that
feather and where do they what party
they go to yeah who is at that party
exactly how did those people have their
no legs and then they would yeah right
yeah so so technology adoption is
actually a social phenomenon they also
looked at things like adoption of rifles
by American Indians adoption of you know
yeah so your so we're talking about how
memes spread right across a planet and
yes that's it that's a really interest
right yeah right cool yeah so and what
you can basically say is the reason that
technology spread so quickly today is
not because of again anything that
really happens in a lab that that does
that does happen faster too because of
you know we have better tools and better
knowledge and yada yada but what makes
it spread so fast is that we're so much
more connected yeah so the fact that
like it used to be you know you and the
people that you would see today were the
only people that would know about your
feather in your hat yeah what color it
was um you know color photography
television those things spread those
memes much one quickly globally and
today you know one kid in Shenzhen can
you do something with a purple feather
in there you know purple hat and then
every kid's got to have that so and that
goes global instantaneously and anybody
can do that
so the decentralization of communication
about not just technology but other
social things you know how we look at
gay marriage or the you know socially
acceptable use of psychedelics or things
that we don't know about in the future
will also go faster and more global more
quickly and that's just almost a law of
nature yeah the law of nature is that
ethics evolve and that now with the
connectivity of everything things are
memes are moving faster yeah yeah yeah I
like how you brought the social cases up
you were teaching me about that earlier
too that these ethics evolving have now
made huge tectonic shifts in
civilization yeah that you know 50
hundred years ago people were like no
way right yeah yeah like what's next
yeah well I think that's we're seeing a
lot of that in the political around the
last few years with you know brexit and
Trump were definitely reactions to this
globalization and sort of changing
things that we thought were you know
forever eternal and changing things like
aspects of identity like gender or
occupation or nationality or religion
those things are now all really really
fluid again for the same reason you know
and so for a lot of people that's very
discomforting and they you know want to
throw a throw a wrench in their through
machine to basically slow it down and I
think brexit and Trump are both
essentially like I'm just gonna throw a
wrench in and we'll worry about fixing
it later yeah yeah there's kind of like
an ebb and flow - it's like a
vicissitude and up and down to like to
globalized okay national like to too
much religion okay atheism yeah there's
like these weird yeah yeah yeah it's so
strange yeah it's like can civilization
work together we all know that's yeah it
won't yeah that is the the big lesson of
history is like we always want to do
that and we never do that and yet
somehow we do move forward together and
I think that the I mean another good
example right now is around climate
change so people are really anxious and
fearful about the effects of climate
change on society on the environment and
on human prosperity and so on and and
that's a really good thing because it is
that anxiety that makes us act that's
right so I was saying you know like I
was a kid in that in 80s and at that at
the time the Cold War was the big sort
of the equivalent then was nuclear
winter yes we were and I'll tell you
what I'd rather have global warming of a
nuclear winter yeah but I'd really
rather have neither yeah and the fact
that people were so you know just so
moved to basically take action led to
political change and other things that
basically help us dodge a really big
bullet and that wasn't the first time so
anyway so I think it's really important
to avoid yeah we have these
conversations and that we hey fear is a
good thing you know motivates us and
yeah yeah I was at multiple points now
through this conversation I've been
doing this very interesting trying to
like go back in time for you to like
through your life how you went with this
like slow trajectory of watching things
innovate and disrupt and see Giants fall
and be really excited about how you can
help others innovate really well and so
that's been exciting for me to immerse
myself in in you in that sense because I
think hopefully helps other people
immerse themselves in you better and see
that lens because then they can bring
that lens to their families and
communities and yeah countries and
people and then potentially that can it
can help a giant and potentially stick
around longer it can help a startup
potentially become more agile and and
get overthrow one of those giants yeah
yes it's like exciting so exciting yeah
I think I mean it's not my lens at all I
think it's more of a bug that I've
caught that others to me and it is this
it's the thing this this it's curiosity
but also your curiosity and thinking are
still pretty passive and so I really
like getting you know hands-on so like I
said when I was at UCSF I mean I liked
what I liked about being in a lab a wet
lab and doing experiments with live
animals or life cells or things like
that was a few you held your hand wrong
or something there's no controls II you
know that animals dead your cells are
gone like your experiments over and you
just lost a week there's no way to go
back to this sort of the focus is is
really really different when you're
working with physical objects and so you
know what I was saying earlier about
making physical prototypes turning those
prototypes into a movie or some you know
some physical embodiment that allows you
to communicate it in a way that just
words and and charts don't that's a you
know that's a that's the process of
invention you want to make something
that then inspires people to solve the
rest of the problems about you know how
do we make this at scale how do we you
know change it so it works better for
people that it wasn't intended for so
hacking and making and
those things are really critical and you
hinted at democratization earlier giving
more degrees of freedom using the cost
of these degrees of freedom for people
around the world to explore their yeah
self-actualization
I want to power around on a couple
things because it they want to pick I
want to you pick your mind and make sure
that other people can learn from you
about these things you were just giving
this example of like the physical world
you heard the digital world you can
control Z but in the physical world you
mess up on your biotech experiment or
even worse you know your neuro tech the
right experiment right I had some bad
news potentially so you know you've been
doing a lot in research and also helping
in with innovation labs neural
interfaces yeah teach us a bit about
that because that's some that's some
interesting stuff yeah so neural
interfaces is again right at this zone
where it sounds like a horrible horrible
idea
you're gonna connect your body and your
brain to a machine that can essentially
read your your bodies your brain signals
to you know other parts of the brain or
to your body so EEG electrodes o'clock
encephalography or EMG electromyography
those are measuring brain and muscle
signals basically G's from muscle right
eat electromyography my ography action
biography kg is like a choreography
sales car yeah so exg right and those
are different parts of exercise it X's
in anything like this o is the CMO CTO
and so on so the extra um I just made
that up that's not really a turn oh but
I like that term go yeah because it's
like any electrical bio signal pretty
right right yeah that's cool
right so so these are things that again
they've been medical devices medical you
know instruments and a lot like the
$40,000 Xerox computer that I mentioned
so these are like 40,000 dollar machines
that you wanted you know to understand
why somebody was having epilepsy you
hook their brain up and you'd like
figure out where that problem is coming
from or you know why are they having
muscle control problems so you hook
their body up and you see you know
what's going on so these this equipment
as it got you know that is they got
obsolete for medical
purposes but was still usable for kind
of hacking and stuff like that people so
saying hmm I wonder what I could do if I
had a you know EEG device at home and
there you know it's it's on eBay now yes
so like that box right right so that
that process has gotten you know through
its cycles the same way I did with PCs
and a lot of that stuff you can hack
together for you know parts that you can
get off of Amazon or Alibaba you can buy
use things point is it's it's like a
middle school science project at this
point whoa yeah so um and then
connecting out with a computer you can
then understand really fine-grained like
what these signals are doing and again
this is stuff you get your PhD for a few
years ago and now it's you know high
school project shout on to Tim Mullen at
Indian who does the actual processing of
the bio signals through the cloud for
cadet easy just ship it to them to me
what yeah yeah yeah again it's it's it
is like literally godlike powers reading
somebody's mind if you go back far
enough I that I mean 10 or 20 years now
anybody can do those things so the so
that sounds really kind of scary like a
computer can read your mind what is that
gonna do and and there's this whole
field called neuromarketing and if
you're worried about like how facebook
does you know ad targeting should wait
till neuromarketing you know google that
so so there's that
that's just thank you Ron go ahead that
that's just the the reading your brain
waves your brain signals part then
there's writing back so if you can
understand like okay this is a signal
that makes my hand go like this or do
like that or my fingers go something
like that because you just recorded it
right off my muscles then what you can
do is flip that around and actually send
a signal back that's strong enough to
override well my brain is feeling those
muscles to do and the machine can make
my arm do exactly what my brain would be
telling so you know again that sounds
super scary and you can things don't
even actually have to be alive for that
to work you can take dead animals and
things like that and do that so that's
actually the experiment that Nicola did
not but Volta did
you basically show took you know
electricity and a dead frog leg and
could make the Frog ride twitch even
though it's dead and separated like
there was still some energy left in them
no no no it's just think it's just what
it's a it's the property of the muscle
of the muscle all right you're not
unleashing anything oh whoa but then
this is just like this is just science
and this is two or three hundred year
old science there's also stimulation
like for better top-down processing as a
top-down yeah management you can maybe
hold your attention longer your hold
your focus sustained attention and focus
so you can actually execute your goals
there's like there's good applications
right what are some other good that the
Innovation Lab is kind of so-so if you
think about like that again that that
ability to read and then write pretty
arbitrarily these signals and it's very
coarse right now it's kind of like that
little you know twenty character screen
on the typewriter
you can't play a piano for example you
can't pick up an egg and sort of move it
around controlling somebody else's arm
but in the future is if we get better
and better at that we think that that's
what we'll be able to do so some of the
the research that people are working on
is for example if you if you're a
paraplegic you've you know lots of
function of your legs you could control
your own legs because your your hands
would be able to control the muscles in
your own legs and you could maybe learn
to walk again because you don't have to
have that signal through your spine you
could have it go through your hands you
could teach somebody to play piano or
play a sport vital yeah yeah so there
are a lot of like really useful
applications that people are actually
pursuing but at the same time again
history shows us that we tend to come up
with really silly applications that the
inventors didn't come up with so you
know again teenagers using social media
to post pictures of all kinds of things
yeah or just even like you know cat
videos and Instagram food photos and
stuff like that that we do we've been
doing that for about ten years now I'm
pretty sure that the guys that invented
ARPANET we're not thinking this would be
really useful for sharing funny cat
videos that's right but I didn't occur
to them yeah so we'll do something with
New York
faces that our kids are gonna think it's
totally normal and fun and we're gonna
go no no no you like you need to you
know put down the neural interface be in
the room with us knows about say there's
a foot way out yeah there's a you know
the eye-to-eye right thing right yeah
screen - hi - I think yeah yeah yeah
some nuts yeah they'll normalize on
something crazy that is unexpected with
neural interfaces and we'll be like yeah
what's going on this is crazy it's like
it mostly entertainment is kind of what
we see a lot of must chimps gravitate
towards entertainer does yeah so there's
a company called nerble and they may
have vulnerable and they make a like a
device it basically puts on the you know
the head straps of a VR system put the
electrodes in that so it's already
you're already wearing this thing and
now it's just like these little combs
are kind of touching your head you have
to shave your head and put gel on it and
stuff like that and then you can control
a video game with your thoughts with
your thoughts yeah and I've prescribed
this out it's it's pretty
you'd really like you think go left and
it goes it's it's you you right now you
get one sort of command yes kind of like
I compared to in the old you know Atari
joysticks you had a red button you're
only pressing the button it said they're
on or off and it's there's no we're
doing in the game so you can actually do
quite a lot with that because it you can
also the joystick in this game is your
head so what you're looking at you know
it can tell what you're focused on and
then you press the button so you like
choose something press juice and oil
sure right but you're you're looking at
it and thinking grab or whatever your
keyword is yeah and you're the future
they'll having to do that activity and
that's what it's reading is like you
want to do it versus you don't want to
do it maybe yeah so there's a to get
kind of technical it's a it's a thing
called an ERP event related potential
and that's a pattern in brainwaves that
it can detach and the idea is that by
finding and so it has to calibrate cuz
everybody's are a little bit different
everybody's brain works differently so
you have to train it a little bit it's
about two minutes but in the future that
you would remember that training it
would have more degrees of freedom again
the same things I was saying about
gaming just getting from one simple red
button to lots and lots of
to freedom so more button was more
essentially joysticks with a continuum
of anklet all right give us on Mars
bound give us some Mars bound because
this is also super exciting yeah yeah
well you know so I was mentioning
earlier you know Park is a what we
sometimes called it a moonshot
organization Google X you know there are
a lot of these parts of companies that
are kind of set off to the side
sometimes physically or often physically
separate from the rest of the company
that are really meant to find things
that are you know out in the future that
are gonna have some disruptive potential
and and be the first to find out so a
really good example there is Airbus has
a group here in San Jose called
a cubed and the impetus for starting
this this group that's meant to come up
with things like flying cars and
reconfigurable aircraft and stuff like
that is with SpaceX so the same way that
you know Apple kind of came out of
nowhere with a phone they weren't a
phone manufacturer but they decimated
the phone manufacturing industry
SpaceX you know Tesla Solar City like
there's no spaceships in there but Yohn
must came up with this company and they
were doing really good and so Airbus the
CEO said as anybody does to our
commercial aircraft business with SpaceX
to do our space business we're dead so
they said we're gonna set up like the
organization that's gonna discover these
things that will disrupt our own
helicopter business our own commercial
airs from aircraft businesses go on yeah
cuz Airbus is the dominant force in
airplanes right now they're in orbit and
Boeing right kind of the duopoly but
yeah but Airbus is doing all of the big
like Airbus a380 is this gigantic plane
and they're the ones that the Middle
East is just purchased up and they're
the new bodies like the major you see
the emirate there yeah yeah they've like
500 or something and like the next not
only has I think every third loved them
to have 500 of a380s but yeah yeah yeah
it is really big plane
don't need that many of them but but
that said yes they are they're big fans
and then so Boeing did a different thing
they went and looked at like composite
aircraft so the 787 is a but plastic
plane basically they didn't use aluminum
just saw must or urged people to get
more into electric airplanes yeah right
so that's it that's it that's a great
example so there's a little syrup called
Zune um there's a bunch of different
companies are trying to make electric
aircraft so the same way that's happened
in automotive the ion I remember posting
about it but I forgot exactly what it is
they don't even need they just move oh
iron propulsion ion propulsion yeah
that's really far out there but you're
right but that input um for very
lightweight it works yeah yeah yeah so
so on the on the surf spectrum here
that's probably a 40 or 50 year thing
right now and so somebody's interested
in that but that's gonna be a NASA
project for a long time the NASA's job
is to get those things to where a
company's moonshot program could say hey
we're gonna take that in so Airbus does
have an electric aircraft program as
does Boeing I'm in a lot of other people
so so that's really how science and
technology has progressed up till now we
had making that really important point
though about Airbus making sure that
they don't lose their power by doing
their innovation yeah right so so the
again that some Mars bound and the name
of my company is you know we're going to
Mars it's beyond the moon and the reason
for that is that moon shots are now you
need to have it like standard practice
if you want to better than standard
practice you need to be looking beyond
that and that's literally what's
happening in space as well so again you
know SpaceX is one of the companies
that's leading the charge to go back to
the moon to colonize Mars and it sounds
like just some you know crazy
pot-smoking
billionaire CEO yammering right but he
sounded like that and he's executed
pretty consistently on a number of
technological challenges and there's
dozens of companies that are going into
space so in about a month so January
24th if I can plug a little event we're
doing so there's a group called hello
tomorrow it's hello tomorrow yeah
so this is a organization that started
in France and that focuses on these you
know these deep innovations across a lot
of different fields and we're having at
Xerox PARC suite the an event to launch
the Silicon Valley hub of hello tomorrow
so I'll be there
basically curating we've got one track
in mobility so the against self-driving
cars one in new space and NASA is the
organization leading that panel and then
in in biotech we're looking at synthetic
biology neural interfaces and things
like that so it's January 24th if you
need a modern a part holla at your boy
you're gonna bait I guess you're on the
list I love it I love it that sounds
like a great event yeah hello tomorrow
Gerry 24th right awesome so yeah if
Silicon Valley i'ts you know and go to
park on that date okay couple quick
questions on the way out do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no expand a
bit on that it just would be it would be
a ridiculous waste of real estate and
material to have like one sentient if
we're even sent it who even knows that's
it gets your next question so are we in
a simulation well yeah I was thinking
about this cuz you know obviously that
that phrase comes up on even on the
coasters here in this room and it's a
great question so I'm gonna maybe I hope
I hope I can give you an answer that
nobody has given you before and that is
this so our definition of a computer has
evolved so much in the last 200 years
from like a mechanical gear driven thing
to like this like vacuum tubes
transistors to now we're talking about
biological computers so synthetic
biology using you know biological
circuits to do logic and computation and
stuff like that so if it's evolved that
much in 200 years that's we so anything
could be a computer and so yes we're
almost certainly living in a computer
question is what is it stimulating
uh-huh right that that new that's that's
pretty damn good yeah I think so I think
it is yes I'm pretty sure it is so now
give us just a tad bit more on
so is that saying that then the universe
is code is that yeah so if you assume
now we're definitely getting into the
sort of fringe realm for me and I'm not
saying fringe on the sort of hocus pocus
side but like where my grip on the
science is pretty you know pretty shaky
but there's a couple different theories
about how the universe works at the most
fundamental level one of them is called
lattice gauge theory yeah you know okay
so you've had a clear way to get kind of
inched us in it but we're still
kindergarteners yeah so that is the aged
theory theory right so I'm and I'm gonna
probably screw this up I really
apologize to all the physicists out
there and yeah but this is anyway have
you ever seen or played Conway's Game of
Life the game of life that the board no
not the not the one where you spin and
like you go through different stages of
life
so Conway's Game of Life is a really con
way it was a really early computer
simulation of essentially you know we
now call cellular automata or you know
sort of open-ended systems so what you
think of basically like a big grid and
every a little bit like go maybe and
there are rules for how those every note
on that grid interacts with its neighbor
nodes and they're very simple rules and
you can you know change them into
different property oh sorry I'm
following where you're I think we're
right so you basically say like if if
this flips to black then you have to
flip all these other exact happens based
on certain rules if-then statements
right so it's a form of logic so lattice
gauge theory is essentially saying
there's a lattice it's not a do
dimensional grid it's a you know n
dimensional lattice we don't know
exactly how many dimensions it would be
but there's a way this that apply to the
way that that yeah right it works right
so that for example what we perceive as
motion is actually more like motion on a
on the diamond vision at the ballpark
where the pixels the grid are staying
the same but there's rules for how one
pixel interacts with the ones you know
to its left right abutment below yes it
did to get that so if that's the
flattest gauge theory again
cause that is for botching probably
every single aspect you and I were are
totally on the same page and the way
that you just the way that it is
explained it through its either absolute
physics nuance or just then it's more
abstract sort of nuances is I think as
long as you can get it right is good
last question what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world
the most beautiful thing in the world so
there's a there's a you know sigur rós
that Icelandic group what is he a sigur
rós oh I think so yeah see Russ okay so
they speak they sing in Icelandic which
for reasons I don't have time to get
into so I I can kind of understand what
they're singing because it's related to
German and Swedish and other languages
that I speak um and they one of the
favorite line in this entire discography
is the the best thing that God created
is new days and oh the best thing that
God created is new days yeah and the
next right so that this we have these
cycles and that like you know there's
the the fact that there's always
something new I think is you know that
when I was a kid I had this like
infinity would make me sick to my
stomach I hated the very concept that
things could just go on forever and and
flipping that into this this like
embrace of the infinite and the you know
the the pinch there will always be new
days
it's the always new that's the the thing
I think is the most beautiful who that's
the first time we've had that that is
really good hmm the always new yeah
gives you something to be excited I'm
really excited about yeah yeah I love it
mark this all been so fun yeah this has
been great Pat also yeah you've had a
lot of fun I'm happy that we got you on
the show we were able to talk about all
things faster future yeah all right
thanks such a pleasure
yeah such a pleasure thanks everyone we
really appreciate you guys tuning in
give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you about
this radical disruption and innovation
and also you know let us know what are
your
goal innovative disruptive thoughts and
ideas that could just overturn certain
industries and giants and go and create
them going to execute them yourselves go
and build the future yourselves everyone
much love thank you Ron for producing
and directing thanks everyone for tuning
in join us on patreon cryptocurrency
help support us help support our growth
and our prosperity impacting more people
we love you all see you soon peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]